il y a encore des affrontements
sporadiques avec les hommes de la
securitate le front de salut national
leur a lancé un ultimatum ils doivent se
rendre avant demain 17 heures sinon ils
seront considérés comme des terroristes
la résistance de ces hommes et tonnes
après la chute de leur dictateur mais en
voyant les images qui vont suivre
on comprend mieux ce sont des images
d'une véritable ville parallèle d'une
ville souterraine bucarest ceausescu
avait créé pour assurer sa défense
personnelle
l'ampleur de ces souterrains vous allez
voir étonne encore même les roumains eux
mêmes
maryse mano on entre ici dans un autre
monde une ville secrète de tunnels
bétonné et sans fin tous les matins les
militaires découvrent de nouveaux
souterrain larmes au point la securitate
y est toujours embusqués
cet ascenseur descend jusqu'à la pièce
la plus secrète la chambre est le bon
coeur personnel de chez oc secours ici
les preuves de son départ précipité avec
les restes d'un repas a abandonné dans
ce frigidaire plus de viande quand
romain moyen n'en consomme pendant
l'année dans ce labyrinthe équipée d'une
climatisation sophistiquée des centaines
d'agents de la securitate pouvait tenir
longtemps
certains ils sont en fort tel cet homme
que les militaires viennent de
surprendre
on cherche d'abord l'éventuelle capsule
de cyanure caché dans la doublure de
savait rien cette fois ci mais une série
de papiers atteste qu'il appartient bien
à la sécurité à la possession d'orange
introuvable à bucarest est un indice
supplémentaire
personne ne connaît l'étendue de ce
réseau peut être des centaines de
kilomètres reliant bâtiments officiels
et points stratégiques de la capitale
la radio a lancé un appel aux
architectes pour qu'il fournisse les
plans de ces galeries